if i were a betting man my prediction
would be
um my prediction would be 11 years
and he probably serves half i think this
is probably someone who ends up in
prison
probably like five years before getting
early release
wow i would say more like 20 years but
we'll have to see what happens i mean i
think if he only gets an 11 year
sentence and he gets out in five or six
years
then people will be just totally
outraged about this especially because
will they have forgotten about it by
then oh maybe they will yeah
um but i think that initially if the
sentence is too light then people will
be upset about it especially after
finding out that he was convicted of
murder
i think a lot of people operate under
the assumption that if you're convicted
of murder then you're going to spend the
rest of your life
in prison if not you'll be put to death
or something like that with a death
penalty i think
maybe people don't necessarily
understand that murder convictions don't
always result in life in prison
and so you know if he's only hit with 11
years or something like that then people
could be outraged over that